making strategy games accessible without
dumbing them down isn't an easy thing I
don't feel that strategy games are like
a huge insurmountable wall but I do
think like many sort of subdivisions of
the game games are we do end up talking
to ourselves a lot and forgetting to lay
out the welcome mat or open the door to
to other players
[Applause]
[Music]
of all the video game genres realtime
strategy is perhaps one of the most
intimidating its games casts players as
puppeteers of grand battles with mouse
clicks and button presses pulling the
strings of countless troops as they
fight for resources Dominion and the
future of civilization
it's no surprise in the RTS games are
ultimately considered a niche enjoyed by
PC gamers the well honed acumen for
strategy but unfortunately in recent
years the strategy genre has come
somewhat stagnant but within the broader
landscape of modern gaming the
fundamental gameplay systems of
real-time strategy have been
democratized and popularized outside of
the traditional PC gaming space titles
such as clash Royale League of Legends
and dota have achieved huge success by
narrowing their focus Canadian studio
relic Entertainment has been at the
forefront of RTS innovation on PC with
games such as Company of Heroes and Dawn
of War but as the genre is specialized
in is finding success elsewhere it's
been forced to reassess and look inwards
and find out when RTS game is in 2017
this year it launches dawn of war three
relics ambition for the long-awaited
sequel is to create an approachable RTS
that can break free of the niche
confines the genre finds itself within
however it hopes to do this without
sacrificing the depth its audience have
come to expect amid an ever-evolving
strategy genre and divisions in its key
fan base relic is fighting a battle for
the future the RTS ahead of dawn of war
threes launch we talk to key development
staff about the game's long journey
through production its failed prototypes
and how it's embracing its new dawn
[Music]
development on Dawn of War three first
started back in 2011 after the launch of
Dawn of War two retribution
however for Alek the journey was wrought
with twists and turns at the time the
studio was working on Company of Heroes
2 while building early versions of Dawn
of War 3 amidst development on both
projects its parent company THQ faced
bankruptcy while its embattled publisher
dealt with financial woes relic was
forced to refocus entirely on Company of
Heroes to despite this shift in focus
the future of dawn of war was constantly
in the minds of its developers as relic
search with a shot of adrenaline it
believed the RTS genre needed the
realities of business kept Dawn of War 3
stranded in development limbo for over
half a decade the dawn of war 3 we have
today isn't the same beast that was
conceived under THQ with our time at
relic we learned that many refer to the
current iteration as dawn of war 3 3 2
hugely different games codenamed Atlas
and Morningstar were in development
after the success of dawn of war 2
retribution THQ bankruptcy however left
relic without a publisher and facing an
uncertain future
he had lost its financial support as
well as the license for what become its
most popular franchise dawn war 3 has
had a you know in some ways a long
history and there was never really a
question of a whether we would make a
dawn of war 3 is just when and how as
you know we used to be owned by THQ and
then THQ went bankrupt and we were
acquired by Sega before the bankruptcy
there had been a start of an earlier
version of Don of war 3 in fact two
earlier versions of dawn of War 3 there
was a the one that was being worked on
near the end of THQ Morningstar we were
with that really trying to embrace big
units because when you look at the
tabletop game and these little guys you
can paint with your little paintbrush
then you got these big things like this
and you're like I want that and that in
the same battlefield like it's it seems
to be like the obvious extension of the
fan
see we had a prototype that was built
and there was it was quite interesting
it had a lot of parallels with what we
have now but it was it was purely in a
prototype stages you know placeholder
assets and you know placeholder map we
only had like one one or two maps that
we've even tried it on but it was about
that time that THQ started to to not
have the resources necessary to keep us
going as a team and it was around that
time that there was a large large
layoffs and our team our project was was
shelved with atlas we really were
wanting to experiment more with Anna I
say experiment more with yeah with other
ideas that are happening in the strategy
genre at the time we built a prototype
off of the The Last Stand gameplay that
would have been a free-to-play product
it was certainly fun it was certainly a
nice evolution of last down and it was
right around that time that that the THQ
bankruptcy was declared and and studios
and publishers started looking at I
piece and and the studios within the THQ
umbrella and we got picked up by Sega
after we were acquired by Sega there was
you know a desire for us to do Donna
were three Sega acquired the rights from
Games Workshop to do that and we were
ready to go yes it was a bunch of false
starts so to speak but it was all it all
informs the Donna war 3 that you have
now a way to think about it is you're
getting like four games and four games
worth of ideas distilled down into one
so that I think that speaks to I think
part of our culture here and our in our
drive and you know our passion for the
genre and the product itself
despite its current ambition to appeal
to a wider audience and make it more
accessible Dawn of War 3 in its various
iterations has always been rooted in
tabletop has always been connected to
that hardcore gaming lineage through its
20 years within the strategy genre relic
has learned to strike the balance
between making a game accessible or also
delivering the depth to make it
mechanically rewarding for genre
enthusiasts but for all their expertise
in the genre they haven't managed to
break through to a mainstream audience
RTS is a complex onra and Warhammer 40k
is a dense universe filled with law
rivaling the likes of Lord of the Rings
and Star Wars relic has been vocal about
dawn of all three being an approachable
RTS set in the Warhammer 40,000 universe
but fans of both have voice concerns
this could mean concessions to gameplay
and an unwillingness to delve into the
complexities of the Warhammer 40k
universe as much as relic wants to
appeal to a wider mainstream audience
its hardcore fans are just as critical
to the success of Dawn of War 3 with
this in mind I fought it fair to put
these concerns directly to the team well
I'd ask them to play the game I think
the community needs to play the game
more I would want to know if they've
played it um thinking about um the
accessibility term as like other
watering down those options
I can't state how far that is from the
truth what accessibility means for us is
how can we make the game more welcoming
to a broader audience right like I
believe that there certainly there's a
ground in the middle right like there's
a like hyper accessible we're gonna hold
your hand through this path and then
there's the super steep learning curve
we're gonna pay more attention to the
complexity of our systems and not to
give you a hand in learning those
systems right because we trust that you
already know what you're doing in having
a complex game if you can't surface that
complexity and it's hidden from you you
never discover that discovering the
complexity you're discovering a tactic
or something like that there's there's
kind of that's like the second level of
like there's just having your combat and
then there's having the discovery of you
as a player be like
oh I can do this I think there's
absolutely room for games that really
focus on the hardcore but just because
you open the door a little wider doesn't
mean the house is any less complex you
know it doesn't mean that there are
fewer rooms in the house as it were so I
would ask them to play it themselves
give it a try
throughout my time with relic they had a
confidence with the balance they've
struck with Dawn of War three but as we
wait for the fans reception on release
day where does this put relic are they
still the powerhouse pioneers of
strategy and other moves they've made
with Dawn of War 3 and indication to the
direction of the RTS genre as a whole
the intent is that this is a return to
you know the high quality games that
we've always done but this is showing
that you know we're back Don war is back
and you know I promise that relic is
going to continue to produce these
high-quality games ultimately those are
the things that it sounds really cheesy
for me to say it right like I believe in
this game to the bottom of my being I've
poured my heart and soul into it
ultimately it's going to be the
consumers the players who are going to
have that judgment it's up to them
whether they loved it or not to me what
I hope we're at is a place where we're
continuing to push the genre and that we
don't so well I was successful so let's
just you know sit on our rest on our
laurels I want to continue to push and
when I continue to to challenge the
boundaries of what strategy can be I
think that that's probably where relic
will continue to go and and I hope that
I'm right that we continue to make and
continue to challenge the the genre
thank you so much for watching this
behind-the-scenes look at the making of
Dawn of War 3 if you enjoyed the video
major hit the like button subscribe and
leave your thoughts in the comment
section down below now personally I'm a
massive Dawn of War fan and I'm a
massive Warhammer fan as well so this
project was an amazing opportunity for
me so I would really love to know your
thoughts if you did like this video well
we've got another one coming very
shortly it's all about relic the history
of the studio and its legacy we spent
maybe two days with the guys in
Vancouver so we've got some great
interviews some great thoughts so I
really hope you check it out so until I
see you on that video I will see you
next time
[Music]
huh